Speaker 1: Welcome back to the David Pakman
show.
I am Farren Cousins sitting in for David Pakman
today and if you want more from me for some
reason, but you can definitely get it on my
youtube channels at YouTube.com slash the
Ring of Fire and YouTube.com slash Ferran
Balance.
So this weekend, this past weekend, Mike Lindell,
CEO of Mypillow, held what he had told us
earlier in the week last week was going to
be the event to end all events, he said.
After this weekend's event, you will not be
able to walk away saying that all of these
claims of voter fraud are a hoax or that any
of this is a lie.
You will all be convinced, he said.
That the voter fraud happened because that
is how serious he is about it and that is
how awesome the evidence that he has was going
to be.
Well, it's Tuesday, so the event ended on
Sunday.
There was 12 hours on Saturday, 12 hours on
And I don't know if you've noticed this.
In case you haven't checked, Donald Trump
is not president again.
There were not massive reports over the last
48 hours of amazing evidence of voter fraud
revealed by the pillow man.
In short, Mike Lindell once again lied to
everybody about everything and instead, according
to reports, spent most of his time over the
weekend complaining about the media, whining
and crying about media coverage of him and
his claims and his multiple now cyber symposiums.
He had a couple lawmakers show up.
Marjorie Taylor GREENE showed up.
We'll get more to that in just a few minutes.
But yeah, no earth shattering revelations.
No.
Oh, my God.
Trump actually won the election claims from
anybody on the left or the right.
He basically paraded a bunch of people up
on stage who said the election was stolen
by.
But nobody gave us any evidence.
You're watching this.
So I'm going to go ahead and assume that you're
not one of the people that thinks the 2020
election was stolen.
Congratulations.
If that does apply to you, because you live
in reality.
I live in reality.
We know that there was no fraud in the 2020
election to the degree that would have overturn
the election results in any state.
Heck, at this point, there's not even enough
to overthrow it in any county, any city, any
election that was held in 2020.
Not enough fraud to overturn any of it.
Instances here and there.
Absolutely.
Most of them Trump supporters, by the way.
But no widespread, no irregularities with
the voting machines, no foreign countries
hacking in with their space lasers to change
the votes.
Nothing in.
Mike Lindell, as I said, has now had three.
Multiday cyber symposiums where before each
and every one of them he swore up and down,
I'm going to give it all to you.
It's all coming out this weekend.
Here it comes.
Get ready for it.
Nothing.
Not a thing.
So, Mike, I got to ask you about where is
the evidence?
You say you've had it.
You've literally now been saying it for over
a year that you're going to do it.
And once you do it, it's all over everybody.
You still don't even do it.
So my question at this point is how can anyone,
even your most diehard election fraud believers,
how can you watch this man lie to your face
for over a year about presenting you this
evidence?
He gets up on stage, doesn't present you anything.
How can you walk away from that and say, this
guy's the real deal?
He's telling the truth.
He's telling it like it is.
You're being hoodwinked.
And honestly, I do still feel sorry for you.
I know I probably shouldn't.
But he is feeding you lies to sell you pillows
and now coffee.
Because that's what this is.
Because on screen the whole time on Lindell
TV, or if you were one of the 1500 people
who watched it on YouTube or Rumble because
that's what they peaked out on their live
stream, 1500.
They had about 400 people in the audience
there.
He gave you pillow codes?
Coupon codes to go use at mypillow e-com dot
com.
Excuse me.
Or my coffee?
Yeah, that's what you got.
Because that's what this is.
I firmly believe this is all just a massive
con job.
Now, that's not to say that Lindell doesn't
believe his own claims.
I also believe that he believes it.
But I also think that he understands this
is the best possible marketing he could ever
hope for.
He still labors under the guise that all publicity
is good publicity no matter what.
Even bad publicity is good publicity.
He wouldn't be putting coupon codes for his
website on the screen throughout the whole
thing.
If he didn't want to use this as a moneymaking
operation.
Folks, you're being had you're being strung
along by a charlatan that knows he doesn't
have any any evidence to back up any of his
claims.
But he can continue to promise you the world.
And they're going to continue to eat it up.
But maybe after this, when just maybe, maybe
there's enough sane people left out there
who had been following in following him.
Then maybe they look at it and they say, you
know what?
I can't.
I've been through three cyber symposiums now
and you've given me nothing.
I have to move on with my life.
I hope that happens.
But I doubt it will